you can turn off Wi-Fi and do this idea
I like that so what if I told you that
in San Francisco I discovered a business
that does 31 million dollars in Revenue
locally here in San Francisco on that 31
million in Revenue it does about 11
million in profit and it's brick and
mortar brick and mortar wow and it has a
hundred million dollars of assets on the
balance sheet you want to take a guess
of what kind of business this is well
it's one of the things you've had listed
but does it involve religion
it does not no oh what is it it is
[Music]
all right we're live
happy labor day we are celebrating by
laboring
yes
right join me in this labor Sam let's do
a labor of love because it is a day of
Labor today's episode is all
about ideas business ideas and
opportunities did you like preparing for
this I love preparing for this I bet you
did not this is not my favorite thing to
prepare for it feels like a book report
whereas my favorite episodes or what I
just find cool [__] throughout the week
and I just go have you seen this this is
cool versus this one I was like oh I got
to like go and like find things that uh
like I gotta seek them out a little bit
more to me this is like you know in a
relationship where you it's like oh our
relationship is just us doing things
together right like I gotta go to the
grocery store come with me to the
grocery store that's that's our date but
you forget that you got to do a date
night once in a while you gotta you
gotta break out the rose petals you
gotta figure out a way to to keep it
spicy to me that's what these these
episodes are where
when we started this podcast it was very
much like what what are ideas business
opportunities for people and that's how
we got that initial momentum because no
one else was doing that and then over
time it's like well listen we're doing
two episodes week we can't be having
like 20 good ideas a week that's not
really how it works so we started
blending in just cool businesses we
discovered interesting things that are
going on in our companies whatever
that's like the that's like the Costco
pizza date night you know what I'm
saying like oh let's go to Costco get
some toilet paper and we'll get a pizza
right that's
that counts right which is which is
great so this is a throwback this is we
uh we sprayed some cologne we we got a
little hair gel and uh and putting on
pants for the first time in a while and
here we go this is date night for MFM
um where do you want to start so I'm
actually very happy that we have one
overlapping thing that makes me pumped
um
and also a bunch of our things are big
which also makes me pumped I do not like
the Small Time stuff
we're gonna have a range though there's
gonna be a couple that are like simple
um what I'll call like more like simple
side hustle it's like here's a way that
you could replace a job you're not
really Gonna Get Rich doing it per se
but you could definitely get to I don't
know 10K a month 20K a month doing this
um
and then we have a bunch of Big Ideas so
I tried to stay away from like complete
moonshot ideas in this in this one I I I
have a few big ones what what do you
wanna can we actually start with I think
one that interests you and I that is a
big one do you want to talk about that
one or do you want to start small first
all right yeah let's go last episode we
gave a preview there was one company we
I don't know if we've ever talked about
it but I can just read your mind and
know that you thought this was cool
but in about
2012 or so I think it's starting 2008
but it got popular in like 2012. there
was a company called clout it was clout
with a k k l o u t
and I remember I was just getting
started like on the internet and I only
had like I had like 4 000 Facebook
friends and that was like considered big
and you this company called clop came
out and basically what you could do is
log in with your Facebook your LinkedIn
your Twitter and I don't even know if
Instagram existed in that way back then
uh or I guess it maybe did whenever it
switched to Facebook but it was really
fascinating because what they would do
is they would give you a clout score and
with that clout score what you would do
is it would it would range between one
and 100 I think there was a time when I
had like a 75 or something Obama was
like a 92 like so give me perspective
and what would happen is it was a
platform for companies like McDonald's
well at least that's who I got I got
like five dollar McDonald gift cards so
like their new promotions they would
basically find out like information
about your background so what you're
interested in what you're posting and
then how popular you are and they would
give you free stuff in hopes that you
would go out and like the experience and
share it
that company was acquired uh they raised
like 40 million dollars they were
acquired in 2014 for 200 million bucks
but I don't think that was a very
successful exit I think that they
probably just sold for the amount of
money that they raised at however I've
been thinking about this idea constantly
and I think it's really really really
cool so the way it got started was in
2017 the guy who started his name was
Joe Fernandez he had some surgery uh on
his jaw something was wrong with his jaw
so his jaw was wired shut for three
months and so he was like in this
hospital bed laying around and he didn't
have anything to do and so he said he he
he just got obsessed with can Word of
Mouth be measurable and so he created
this API or he created this program
where you could pull from Twitter's API
and give a score out of a hundred based
off of how influential the person was
and he got obsessed with this and he
started going around deeper and deeper
and deeper on this and eventually it
turned into a company where by like 2011
it was pretty popular
and this one person
um said something amazing where they're
trying to hate on clout and they said
something like uh they took the cloud
took the entire spectrum of human
interaction and condensed it into a two
number a two-digit number that you could
use to bludgeon anyone who failed to
adhere to its uh it basically just said
it's tacky it's basic it's cheap and
they're like you you you can't just put
someone's like give someone a score and
that'd be their self-worth and in my
head I'm like well that's actually
awesome that's a really cool service and
so the company got quite popular it was
bought in whatever I said 2014 by
lithium which I don't even know what
that is and it doesn't exist anymore and
I was curious about it and I said Joe I
we dm'd them I go do you think that this
could still exist today he goes this is
something I'll never get over in so many
ways we were just way too early the
world still needs something like this uh
like clout more than ever unfortunately
I'm not sure if it's possible to pull
out uh to pull it off and get all the
data however the idea of clout for
anyone one in the in our era like just
getting started in the 2010-2014 range
this was awesome and I think a business
like this 100 should still exist because
when we're sponsoring influencers and
stuff for different companies it's
really hard to know what's legit and
what isn't so what do you think about
Cloud what did you remember I remember
back then I thought it was such a smart
idea I was like oh this is great yeah
like everybody you know across all
social you have followers but we all
kind of know followers ain't exactly it
and um to layer on on just another
number that even if you thought it was
stupid
you didn't want to be at the bottom and
I was like oh that's good that one it's
a powerful draw right it's just like any
other ratings or reviews but I was like
this is great because it doesn't require
people to have ratings and reviews they
could just
basically crawl the data or just take
the connected data and give you a score
based off of it so I really like that on
the other side it was unclear to me
exactly how this was going to be used so
for example you're saying when we're
figuring out whether to pay and you know
who which influence to sponsor or how to
pay them uh you know something like this
is useful
problem with this that it was more
compelling to the cloud user who wanted
their score to know their score and for
it to go up than it was for the brands
who needed to find influencers and so I
think it really had half of the problem
I think the second half
like it wasn't a must-have because for
example you can you know you kind of
like if you're a brand you kind of know
who influencers are even if you don't
know you could look at the followers you
can look at their rough engagement say
okay how many likes to followers you get
a very quick proxy for this you could
use cloud but I'm not going to pay cloud
like 30 grand a year for that type of
information so the question is what type
of information what would be the the
right way to use that clout score how
could they what could they do with that
cloud score and I I don't know what that
answer is but I think that's where you
would have to start if you wanted to
restart this idea what do you think what
do you think people could do with this
or do you agree with me that
it's hard to charge a brand a lot of
money for what's somewhat obvious which
is uh you know which influencers have
have pull I think you're thinking like a
small medium-sized business owner and
not McDonald's and not like a huge card
I think it's like a 50 million dollar a
year business not a billion a really
funny story uh so I had I did an
interview with Emmett or I did applied
with Emmett uh the other day so Emmett
is the CEO founder of twitch and twitch
had bought my company and so anyways I
uh it went well overall it's gonna come
out in a couple days but
there was one really funny part where he
just burned me so bad and I was just so
shook by it I couldn't even like it took
me like five minutes mentally to recover
from this I was so embarrassed by it
well you texted me you said uh he said
something to me that stuck in my head
and it almost really makes me so hard so
like I was trying to set him up for like
dude uh I learned so much from you I was
like I learned so much from you and uh
one of the things you taught me was this
cool little model during our first
one-on-one you were like oh hey here's a
here's a good way to use uh like here's
a good way to like format these
conversations here's like a way to plug
it like here's here's a way to use me if
I was a piece of Machinery here's a
manual on how to use it and he's like
you can come in and you can say one of
three things you can be like hey I'm
doing this FYI uh you know here's my
decision FYI here's my the second one is
here's my dis here's what I think we
should do do I have your approval right
maybe it's very risky it takes a lot of
money to do it third one I don't know
what to do can you help me and fourth
one is LA last time we talked about this
and here's where I'm at now and like
that's the update and I was like that
was really useful is that something that
you figured out like where'd you learn
that I was trying to get a sense for it
and he was like he's like yeah that's
really good for like mid-level managers
and I was like oh man he's like if
you're a super seasoned executive I
guess I would do it differently but
that's really good for you're not Junior
but you're not like a super seasoned
exec and I was like it's absolutely
absolutely true I'm not a super seasoned
corporate executive I've never I think
that's what the word where the word mid
has come from yeah but I was like I
don't want to be mid-level anything like
you could be like hey what floor are you
staying on I'm like I'm in the 19th
Floor they're like I thought he'll tell
Keith said ninth I was like no no I
don't stay in the mid level of nothing
I'm not don't ever put me there and so
he burned me and I was like uh he didn't
even he wasn't trying to burn me he was
trying to be totally nice but in my head
I was like oh my God I just got burned
and then for the next five minutes I
don't even know what he said and then I
came back to the interview after that
well you should have brought that up
you're like look I can't get this out of
me I should have did you which is good
you know when you have that like
compounding social awkwardness where
it's like the thing hap you know uh I'm
checking into my flight they say have a
nice flight and I say you too you too
yeah and then I'm like oh screwed up and
then you're like what I sure just do is
laugh it off right now like a smooth guy
and instead
you just pause you eat it and now it's
like oh now it's been too long and then
you're kind of you're in your own head
about it so that's that's what I did uh
at least you you accidentally call them
it Mom you had one of those moments
like when I said it was like 55 minutes
later but like ah just circling back to
that mid-level thing I know you didn't
mean that right can you say that
differently in a way that feels better
to me
is he like genius is is he like one of
those guys that's the other problem too
you can't even be like ah this idiot
doesn't know what he's talking about
it's like no this genius knows exactly
what he's talking about
is he working at twitch still no he
retired that's sick all right well maybe
Emmett will be the new CEO of twitch or
uh cloud or something like that I don't
know what's he gonna do now like go to
Mars I mean he's like pretty wealthy now
yeah I think he's gonna do like uh you
know other stuff in life we talked about
a little bit on the Pod but I think he's
gonna like he wants to write a lot like
essays and stuff like that like he was
in the first YC batch I think he looks
up to Paul Graham who's sort of a mentor
for him and and then he really likes
other people who have kind of like
really contributed to like the
intellectual discourse of the world and
I think that's what he wants to do when
for the next little period of his life
not go back and operate another company
he did that for 17 years which is pretty
intense and Paul Graham lives I think
like as ideal life as one can like he
just like go yeah I think he lives in
England now with his family and he just
writes an essay once a month and
everyone just does what he says uh you
know what I mean like the whole the the
YC Illuminati they just yes sir uh so it
works out well um all right so Cloud I
think is a cool idea but what do you got
so restarting Cloud okay I think that's
good I think I got a different version
of uh of an idea that
that was some uh like similar sort of
Professional Services okay
so we've had Andrew Wilkinson on the
podcast a bunch and Andrew is a fan
favorite and people I think like us
really respect what he's done with tiny
it's like oh tiny we buy businesses we
buy wonderful businesses beautiful
businesses right it's a great little
stick and he's got a portfolio of I
don't know 30 companies now at this
point and uh the whole thing is worth I
don't know what's the stock worth today
maybe 700 million or something like that
six to eight hundred On Any Given weeks
Amazing so amazing sort of bootstrapped
um Venture and he bootstrapped it
because
two of the businesses out of the 30 are
the real crown jewels meta lab which is
his design agency and the other one is
dribble and dribble is a business that's
very very simple which was
it is based on the simple Insight every
career
needs its online resume right every job
that you're going to do needs a a way
it's for you to show what you're all
about and get more jobs and so for most
jobs we have like the catch-all the
generic which is LinkedIn so LinkedIn is
going to say
um hey just put a put a resume up here
just say what you've done and hopefully
that's good enough
but for some jobs you need something
more special so for example if you're a
designer LinkedIn doesn't really help
you stand out that much but now dribble
would let you go and post designs so
design shots so like just like
screenshots or or images of what you're
designing as your portfolio and it
became a portfolio site and so dribble
itself is probably worth
250 million dollars I want to say
um that's fine I'm trying to find the
financials I'm trying to find the
financials but it looks like in 2022
dribble did 8 million in profit but I'm
pretty sure that uh it's like here it is
uh it did uh 60 so in 2022 it did 62
million in Revenue with 8 million in
earnings and because it's a network that
could definitely sell for four or five
times Revenue depending on its growth
rate
um yeah exactly so it's pretty valuable
so I think 250 million dollars probably
what dribble is worth now uh another
friend of the Pod Scott belski did the
same thing with behance he created B
hands which is a place for designers to
post their work to as a sort of a
community for those designers to comment
on each other's work but the business
model was if you want to go hire a
creative come to be hands and so dribble
and B has both did the same thing I
think he sold behance For What 100
million something like that no I think
it was 175 of which she owned 60 or 70
percent of it amazing so what does that
take me now okay so where can you apply
this dribble or behance model that needs
it today so
Zuck I think seven years ago said
something he goes
video is a mega trend hey I was like
what what's a mega trend is that like
he's not Zuckerberg is not the type to
just say like flowery words like when he
says something he's he's part of the uh
words mean things team
um and so what's a Megatron he's like a
mobile is a mega Trend the internet was
a mega Trend and now video is a mega
Trend and he's like basically video
everything is who else is on that team
who's also I stole that person Emmett
calls it words mean things and I saw him
in many many meetings derail the entire
meeting
because he was stuck like you said this
word what does like what does that word
mean and they're like uh I don't know we
all know kind of right he's like I don't
know does it mean this or this and then
he's like he's like no because words
mean things to me and so if we're gonna
use words
they're gonna mean things and we're
gonna all agree on what those words mean
so that we can have a productive
conversation and I was like wow well
it's the words means words mean things
teams otherwise known as serious people
you know like oh he's he's a serious
he's he's serious people like when they
say a handful of words you're like I
know he or she specifically chose that
word I love those types of people he
calls it uh words mean things versus
Team alliances and I don't know what
team Alliance is there's a longer uh
there's a longer explanation to that but
um he's like you know there's sort of
like two the way people think is in two
two teams and one is like oh let's not
get lost in semantics and the other is
like semantics is everything that's how
we're that's how we are going to
communicate
um let's let's not
be weak about that let's words mean
things let's agree on that
um anyways so
Zuck said this Megatron thing and if you
look at it everything has shifted to
video so entertainment Netflix streaming
all that obviously onto video news is
highly video education has become driven
a lot by video e-commerce is driven by
let's say video ads and uh how you're
going to display your product
um communication stupid podcast with
zoom please
audio is becoming we now have to we now
have to go to YouTube and I have to wear
like a nice shirt sometimes yeah I did I
wet my hair like you know I used to do
in school in the water fountain I wet my
hair before the fudge there's a quick
little spruce up so videos just make a
trend but where do you hire people that
specialize in working in videos so where
do hire people that are video editors or
um or even like the auxiliary things
like thumbnail artists or uh video
strategists where is their behance where
is their dribble where can I go see
portfolios or like a news feed of people
who did really cool animations or um
cool edits
um to a video and then be able to hire
those people and some of who's hiring a
lot of video people I don't find this
site I think if somebody created behance
for video I think that that is a that is
a big idea dribble for video I think
that is I completely agree
I 100 agree and uh I'll explain why so I
actually had a very similar topic that I
was going to bring up I was going to
call it LinkedIn for x and the reason
being is I think I think you told me
about this it's called Uh dot docs is it
docsaminity doximity doximity uh so
basically it's LinkedIn for doctors you
told me about it so I didn't realize it
it's publicly traded it has a four or
five billion dollar valuation it's a
great business so it's basically which
by the way LinkedIn context it has I
think two million doctors LinkedIn
probably has
I don't know 300 million people or
something like that hundreds of millions
of users fractions and Linkedin sold for
20 billion doximity you said is at 4
billion so it's no five four point eight
five okay so it's only four times less
valuable than LinkedIn with 100x less
customers right because the value per
customer is so much higher yeah and and
so I was reading about it and they had
this term that I loved they go we where
we launched this because we are always
looking for digitally digitally under
indexed Industries and I thought that
was a beautiful word
and so what that means is basically
communities of professionals who just
aren't aren't being catered to in a
digital format so you could say lawyers
you could say um I actually don't even
know what else I mean there's a lot of
them there's one there's one for blue
collar workers called job case and the
reason why this interests me is at
Hampton
what I'm noticing is that even though we
didn't mean to do this we're sort of
becoming a little bit of a network not
quite a social network but I'm seeing
I'm like if we wanted to which I don't
really want to we could make this like a
have you heard of Raya do you know what
Raya is yeah the dating app for hot
people yeah it's like well I I think
they call it like Elites or something
but it's like a paid dating app for like
Elite so like the for the facial we
Elite yeah or or or the the the the uh
Bank Elite you know like if you have it
depends she's gonna start saying instead
of a socioeconomic underprivileged I'm
facially underprivileged and uh I've
been able to overcome this this
adversity yeah well and this [__] has
gotten me really interesting because I
think that what you can do which
basically what how do you call it DOC
City
doximity what does that mean that's some
see you have to know how to say the word
in order to even get in sounds like a
drug words mean things sounds don't even
mean
uh but this company dude so they're
growing quickly they're doing like 400
million in Revenue 150 million in income
so they've been profitable for years and
they've built this LinkedIn for doctors
and they think it's a really good
business and what I've been really
fascinated in uh fascinated about is
what type of niches can you build
professional networks uh that are
somewhat ignored because do it on do go
on to LinkedIn yeah I use LinkedIn what
is your inbox on LinkedIn look like
right now oh I just ignored the inbox
mostly exactly why do you do that it's
mostly mostly junk and uh expand yeah so
it's crap it's crap the inbox of
LinkedIn is horrible no networking is
happening there
and like people mostly use it for resume
tracking and things like that but
there's a bunch of jobs out there like
lawyers like doctors where it's a
relatively small community two million
people three million people I think
there's two and a half million lawyers
in America there's 2.1 million doctors
in America these are relatively small
where you could have small it like
circles that know 80 of the population
on the network because I'm a friend with
you who starts with you and then now I'm
connected to you and like it's small
enough and so I've been really
fascinating very similar to the dribble
thing dribble is a little bit more
resume in showing off portfolio work uh
this is a little bit more networking and
but it's also resume I've been very
fascinated by these businesses that do
this and the hard part I think with any
social network
is it's like what's the Chicken and the
Egg problem which is like you know it's
not good unless we have users but we
don't have any users and we need users
yeah um but what I've noticed is that
there's so many people on young-ish
people on Tick Tock who are
professionals that are crushing it so
there's a like a bunch of dentists or
orthodontist people tons and tons of
chiropractors like there's lots of like
Professional Services that are going
viral on Tick Tock and if I'm in this
position which I guess I kind of man am
where I'm thinking like what else can we
do Hampton for I was like man I could
totally partner with some of these like
and create a Hampton for doctors but to
do a social network I was like I'm
that's not my skill set so I'm not good
enough to do that but I bet if I could
like convince some crazy person like
Nikita beer someone who knows about
networking or networks Network effects I
think you could actually build a
substantial size business for Niche
professional communities whether they're
paying a small fee to be part of it or
you build an ad Network on it
um but I'm very fascinated by these like
Niche communities for professional so
services that are more than communities
but like uh like LinkedIn Style yeah I
think these are super hard and um would
you do them they're obviously very very
valuable any network is really really
valuable once you create it but I think
these are very very difficult it's
really hard to have one idea which is
why like I don't think there's like 10
ideas like this I think like right now
there might be one or two ideas of this
that might work which is why for the
video one I got excited because
I think that it's it's not always take
all it's well it's clear that there's an
industry where you need this and that
showing how good I am as a video editor
through my paper resume is bad so you
need like you need a paper resume to not
tell the story
then you need for there to be a lot of
people in that industry and a lot of
people hiring for that industry that's
the combo you need and that's why I
think that this uh sort of dribble for
video editors is a multi-hundred million
dollar idea if somebody would uh would
pull it off all right we kind of tag
teamed that one a little bit what you
want to go next
here's a different kind of idea so
here's an idea that I think would be
um
it's not doesn't require the internet
you can turn off Wi-Fi and do this idea
I like that it's not easy
but it's also not really impossible
either uh so it's somewhere in the
middle
um and also on the on the upside I think
it's also like on the low end you make
millions of dollars a year on the high
end you make tens of millions of dollars
a year
so what if I told you that in San
Francisco I discovered a business that
does 31 million dollars in Revenue
locally here in San Francisco
no no no Revenue outside of San
Francisco
uh on that 31 million in Revenue it does
about 11 million in profit and and it's
brick and mortar brick and mortar wow
and it has a hundred million dollars of
assets on the balance sheet
you want to take a guess on what kind of
business this is
well it's one of the things you've had
listed but does it involve religion it
does not no
oh what is it it is a private elementary
school
so no way there are private elementary
schools in San Francisco so so one I
looked at a bunch of them uh the one the
one I think that does the best or the
one that I found that does the best is
one called uh the Hamlin school and it's
based in San Francisco it's a non-profit
so you can see all the financials online
but you can see this for for many of
them
and um
it's just for girls it's it's a girls
only School k through eight I think and
uh
only 450 kids so 450 girls go to the
school you pay basically a college level
tuition so parents pay forty thousand
dollars a year to send their kid to
kindergarten or first grade gosh damn 40
Grand are you gonna do that I'm not
gonna I'm out of the city now but um
the there's a lot of people that do
because they have waitlist and hardcore
admissions process if you want your
kindergartner to get into school you
have to dress up go to the interview
prep them be like hey don't make a fool
out of us we've been preparing you for
four years for this come on perform do
the thing and uh you send them in and
they do an interview with them your your
four-year-old does an interview oh I
know this school I used to play
basketball and they have a sick
basketball hoop uh overlooking the city
yeah yeah that's at the top of pack
Heights and yeah yeah yeah
and so there's a wait list of parents
dying to get in and they own the
buildings they own the real estate that
they are that they operate out of which
is why they have so much uh like so many
so much value and assets on the balance
because they own like huge properties in
the prime spots of San Francisco
um
so and I looked at a bunch of these
there's another one Burks and another
one there's a whole bunch of these that
that exist and they range from like you
could see okay 20 20 21 how much revenue
they do okay they did 15 million or 20
million in Revenue some are more
profitable than others so Hamlet is
particularly profitable but the other
ones would be like 15 to 20 million in
revenue and 2 million in profit
um still not bad not bad at all and they
and they would have 25 million in assets
on the on the books and you could see
who goes there because they have to list
who donates so you can see the donations
from different families oh that's the
Facebook executive and this person is a
a famous author and famous movie
producer and whatever right so there's a
whole how much do they donate like
what's a big donation top donations are
like low seven figures right now but I
think you know like they did like uh
we're gonna renovate the school and they
raised 50 million dollars to renovate
the school and that's donations outside
of the tuition so that's just just
please give us money so we can have a
better building and you get to we'll
name the library after you type the
thing pretty insane
um so there's a huge number of people
because the public school system in San
Francisco is not very good uh or
considered to be not very good I have no
idea what it actually is but that's the
reputation it has
um so I think there's an opportunity to
do the following so so the good for them
now what's the opportunity the
opportunity is
if you were ambitious enough you could
look at and if you cared about this
topic if you cared about this topic you
really got to care about this [__]
because this is going to be yeah I don't
know debatable I think you have to care
enough
um I don't think you have to like be
born to educate I don't think you're you
know you have to be whatever Miss
Doubtfire here like you I think you have
to be a smart person who is going to
hold a standard just like you would for
any other business a man dressed as an
elderly woman you you definitely don't
have to be in that that's that's not
required in fact in fact you can't be
that probably when I think about what
the most ideal teacher is it's Miss
Doubtfire so um a 40 year old
so there's all these so commercial real
estate is that like an all-time low in
San Francisco there's empty buildings
everywhere why because remote work it
was too expensive and now these
companies are basically just trying to
get out of their leases so on one hand
you have huge office buildings that are
going vacant and on the other side
totally dead down there right now uh no
it's not totally dead but it's the
lowest it's ever been so you know Buy
Low if that's your strategy this is a
good time to do it so I think you could
buy one of these commercial or
industrial buildings
and convert it into a private elementary
school now we're going to need a couple
things we're going to need a name and a
differentiator on the name side
I got a few to throw at you you tell me
which one you like well but let's just
go look at a bunch of old shipwrecks
that boogiest names I found here we go
would you like your child to attend
Windsor Oaks
would you like your child to attend the
prestigious Carrington school that one's
nice and the other one is oh yeah yeah
our daughter got into Thatcher Darby
and if your daughter gets into
thatchered RV you feel pretty good right
now so are these just famous like
streets in England I just looked up
expensive ass last names that was my
Google search and then I found a list of
100 and then I started pairing two
together like Windsor Oakley and and
Thatcher Darby
um together so I think I got some some
solid leads there the other thing is we
need to differentiator and when I talk
so I have some friends who who have kids
that go to these schools and I asked
them I said what what would you wish was
different and they're like because I was
like you're paying a crazy price I
thought they would say something like
price or teacher student ratios and they
said they were like no no look these are
all going to be expensive and in fact
I'm fortunate I did well the number one
thing I want to spend on is my kids
education if I you know if there was a
cheaper school I don't think we would
switch because we would feel like well
are we really going to try to go for
like a lesser education I don't know
this was a wait list the price is not
the problem
and I said teacher student ratio they
said now it's six teachers for every one
kid so on the 450 kids they have 75
teachers to run this school that does 30
million dollars you did it the wrong way
six students per one teacher correct
correct got it yeah six teachers for one
student would be insane
um so
um though I said what's the biggest
paintball they go you know what I hate
to say this uh I I consider myself a a
liberal person Live and Let Live
but there's like an agenda in these
schools and the agenda is like very woke
so you know like our kids in elementary
school have like they're being taught
um you know that there are like you know
what is gender you could be a boy but
you're a girl they're like I just don't
want my like
first grader to be thinking oh I could
I'm a girl but I could be a boy like
that and this is in public schools right
this is that the private school oh and
so they're like you know and you know
there's just such a heavy in influence
they they said you know it's crazy in
our elementary school there is um
there are like uh clubs that are you
know it sounds like what you would have
at like maybe a a very liberal college
but it's like yeah I don't feel like
that has a place in elementary school
just like kids be kids so the
differentiator is going to be hey what
happened to schools teaching math and
science let's do that right that's what
we're going to teach we're not going to
teach political stuff we're not going to
treat all these social issues like their
kids let them be kids we're going to be
a hardcore math science stem education
School we're the best this one is no no
that's this is that's what Thatcher
Darby's gonna be
um I love it hardcore Math Science and
we don't subscribe to all we keep the
the politics out of the school that's
that's our only promise you're here to
learn and we're going to learn
these topics and uh we're not trying to
shape your kids socially or politically
in any way you and I have a friend who's
got a well he's just turned he just
became a teenager 13 and I said hey uh
hey Brian how's school going uh you know
it's about that age you're you're liking
girls I bet you you anyone you'll have a
crush on uh no it's not really working
out well why not he goes they're all
non-binary and uh I'm just like what
because
yeah there's only one that's
heterosexual uh in assists or something
like that but the rest are non-binary
and the girl I like is non-binary so she
said she can't be with me and I was like
all right well that is a pain in the ass
I don't know what to say to that yeah no
advice I have no idea what you're
talking about yeah
yeah so what do you want to have for
lunch like it was it like it it sounds
really challenging honestly most of the
times Generations will say like oh you
have it so easy I had it so much harder
when I was your age
not true here I do not envy a 12 or 15
year old in in that at that age right
and I I don't know if it's better or
worse not really saying that but I do
think there should be options in the
market for what you want some some
people really really do want their kid
to be
um exposed to a whole bunch of different
issues it'd be a well-rounded human
being and well-versed in a bunch of
different issues and other people are
like you know I don't really want my kid
thinking about that I just really want
them to have a good education learning
about math science you know reading
writing those things and I'd like the
school to do that and I will handle the
kind of like the outside of of those
that curriculum type of education so I'm
not saying what's your phrase it'll be
like to be different where where
well-roundedness goes to die
or something like that
hardcore science machines
we don't like uh standardized testing we
love it yeah so yeah you've got
something here diversity here is
Javascript
all right that's cool but that's crazy
that school makes that much money yeah
who would have thought I didn't really
think about like ever like oh
create a school that that school if it's
doing you know
you know any of those schools those are
basically like somewhere between 50 and
200 million dollar assets if you were to
sell them maybe more if they one of them
has 100 million dollars in assets on
this balance sheet like
um these are these are very big
businesses that are just one location
brick and mortar schools with 400
customers that's kind of amazing did I
ever tell you about the time I was a
telemarketer
No
so at my high school
if you needed some money the best job
was to be a telemarketer and what were
we selling for what yeah what were we
selling you ask we were begging for
money and so what they would do is you
would get paid ten dollars an hour but
you'd get a commission and you get pizza
and I worked that job for a year three
nights a week and what they would do is
every time you'd sit down at your desk
in the evening they pay commission
salary and pizza dear diary yeah that
was the thing it was like I was 16 that
was the thing we had dinner it was they
had soda and pizza and you'd sit down at
your desk I'd worked I worked there from
like 3 P.M to like 8pm you sit down at
your desk and you have a phone and then
you just have a box of note cards and on
the note cards it says how much the
person donated previously what their
resume is so where they worked and what
their age is and what you would do after
this is a little uh trick of the trade
you find the oldest person there who's
got the best career or who has
previously donated the most amount of
money and you line those up and you just
start calling them and you say you know
hey mister uh hey hey Mr Smith this is a
Sam at Slough your alma mater I know you
graduated here in 1956
um but look things are going great here
but we need some money in order to build
this thing or that thing can I count you
down for a five thousand dollar donation
you did three thousand dollars two years
ago but times have changed my friend we
got to step it up like you want to be a
man for others or not now is the time
and like we would like we had these
scripts that we had to like sell these
guys on giving us money to build
something and I would bring in I don't
remember the exact numbers but like tens
of thousands of dollars a month in
donations from these alumni and that was
my job was just to call these guys
constantly and we would do I don't know
maybe 100 calls or something like that a
night just trying to get this money and
you would get like if you brought in
five grand boom you got a hundred
dollars like that's what we did and it
was the greatest racket on it I don't
remember exactly no we weren't making
because the money had to go to the
school was this legal or was like you
know was there a janitor overseeing you
what was going on here who was running
this program I can't believe the history
teacher who do you yeah as a history
teacher that was that was like his side
job his side hustle was running the
Boiler Room
you know he was the Jordan Belfort and I
was like the little uh the little scrum
or the little scrub just like you know
smiling and dialing he's like you guys
want some crackers yeah yeah
workers are for closers
on the phone part yeah you're like walk
behind you like Sam is that a work call
could you please uh can you please hang
that up and
your finger's broken why aren't you
dialing bar
but that's what I did it was awesome I
mean don't you have that doesn't Duke
people call you and usually what they do
is now what they do is once you get old
enough they hire your friends to be the
person so like if we went to Duke
together I'm gonna call Sean and be like
hey Shawn
what yeah so like my high school now
I'll get texts from people who I was
acquainted acquainted with and I'm
friends with and here's the kicker
they'll say [__] like hey I know I
follow you on social I know you're doing
real well
um
you got a baby on the way you know that
maybe yeah like so it's like do I flex
right now like because I'm entirely
driven by making my high school friends
or my high school classmates like I want
to be a big shot to them that's right
because you know I got made fun of it
that's all that's all I care about is is
bringing it back to them
but I Gotta Give five grand to this
[__] school they get me all the time
it's been working so effectively but
that's how these telemarketing things
work you don't get calls from duke
asking to give money hey it's dude lose
my number
parking up the wrong tree never
happening can't believe I gave you the
money I gave you the first place
yeah man it's like a pretty funny uh
thing I mean that's how I have a
multi-billion dollar endowment you gotta
lose my number you're not calling me for
money that's not [__] right if my
high school or something called me all
right maybe I hope they don't but you
know I I wouldn't really feel as
aggressively upset as I do if do calls
if your number could also be a country's
GDP you're if your endowment could be
confused with like a Caribbean country
it's jealous yeah yeah yeah yeah we're
out like you should not call me yeah
size
12 billion is it really 12 billion and
Duke's not even like a dare say good
level there's a good level
it's a mid major it's definitely a mid
major it's not even a good school
I made a Duke top 20. it's top 20 for
sure right yeah it is yeah is it but is
it top 20 thing in terms of endowment
yeah I think so I think so that is
insane billions of adults billions of
dollars in endowment they could
basically just run the school off the uh
investment income oh yeah totally uh I'm
surprised that um more people I'm
surprised that anyone gives to these to
these schools I don't understand at all
all right so the top yeah it's in the
top 20. so Harvard number one is 40
billion Yale two at 30 Texas 30 Stanford
27 and then
at the bottom of the top 20 is Cornell
with 7 million
that's insane that is insane that's
that's
ridiculous yeah I don't know why those
guys would be calling you but I bet they
do they need your fifty dollars
[Music]
see most crms are a cobble together mess
but HubSpot is easy to adopt and
actually looks gorgeous I think I love
our new CRM our software is the best
HubSpot grow better
well I'll tell you about one of the
really smart ideas was this thing called
uh
got the name of the parent company Ben
see if you can find it it's uh they made
this thing called Tower view Venture so
one of the big streets at Duke campus is
Tower View and it's like the name of
some magazine there or something like
that it's like a it's like a reference
to something we remember from from
school and it's basically Tower view
Ventures we're raising money for uh for
adventure fund to invest in alumni from
duke it's like oh yeah Duke has really
smart people
um
so you know we are going to invest those
companies they've had these winners
before Cameo and blah blah blah blah and
they basically do this for they spin
this up for every single top school it's
called I think alumni Ventures and they
just spin up small funds for every
single school and
um and then they just run ads and call
you try to get you to donate try to get
you to invest in their fun and they're
like cool we're just gonna have like
like tarvery Ventures they have uh I
guess started in 2019
there's uh you know it's on fun five now
for for the Duke one and like I don't
know how big These funds are but like
even if they're like 10 million 10
million dollar funds or 20 million
dollar funds you take two percent every
year of management fees and twenty
percent of carry across this times 50
other schools it's like a pretty genius
way to like pull a large rate of so it's
a real business school but there's are
are they does the school give them
permission to use their name well they
don't use their name they say we're
Tower of Avengers and we're investing in
Duke alumni so they're not saying
but they very much make it dude
colors match it's like here's all your
school colors everything is like uh uh
you know based off that
that's a scheme that's a that's a
hardcore scheme right you could do that
for Belmont well I mean like like a 50
000 fun Ain't Gonna Go Far do you think
you're like Bail Bonds most successful
alumni from your year yeah yeah uh no I
got beat you know who it was who Florida
Georgia Line what you know that Florida
Georgia line that band no
you've never heard of Florida Georgia
territory that was annexed
Florida Florida Georgia Line is like if
you go to just your Spotify right now
and like you look in the top 100 songs I
bet most years they have one or two
songs
yeah you know it's on cruise like even
Nelly made an appearance I mean you're
just dude do you know who Nelly is would
you like to pants me right now in front
of everybody you know I don't know who
any of these people are I know Nelly but
yeah it's like Mike Posner was in my ear
and uh you know no do you know Morgan
Wallen do you know who that is he's the
[__] I love that guy they're more famous
than Morgan Wallen oh wow so not not to
you but they put they helped put Morgan
Wallen on the map because Morgan Wallen
appeared on one of their songs anyway
they're like a Morgan Wallen famous band
so they might be number one I think I
might be number two but you know what
they never [__] call me I got mad at
them because here's let me explain why I
got mad at him my mom was gonna come and
watch me graduate but I didn't finish
school on time and I asked like the
teachers or whatever I was like can you
just give me like a fake diploma and
just let me come on stage and not tell
her and I'll finish it at another point
and they're like no it's a tradition you
have to we have to literally hand you
your diploma there I'm like just give me
an empty folder I don't I don't just I
literally just want to be there on stage
just let me have that empty folder and
they wouldn't let me do it and so
forever I'll wow I hate Belmont because
they wouldn't let me just walk in the
stage and just let me shake that guy's
hand and turn the [__] stupid Beret
thing to the side and they wouldn't do
it so I I will always be mad at Belmont
for that reason wow what an L for them
all right I got I got a couple more so
um let me see where I want to go okay
can I can I just rapid fire for you some
ideas go we don't even have to discuss
them okay uh
exporting and you know my import export
framework my import framework and expert
framework is uh if you're at a company
and you wish some you're like dude we
would totally pay for this that's a
business idea you would want to import
you're better off going and starting
that business because it's probably 100
other businesses like you that would pay
for that or export is we we built this
for ourselves
and it's so useful
you're better off leaving the company
and then rebuilding that on the outside
of the walls and selling it to other
companies so here's what slack did
um yeah exactly slack is a good example
of this
um
uh so Paul Graham tweeted this out the
other day that like YC has its own
directory internally about Investors
where any startup founder can go look up
any investor and read their reviews or
kind of like what's the scoop on this
person have they done anything effed up
are they really helpful what's their you
know what do we know about this person
and he's like this is one of the best
products that YC has and I'm like why is
that a product only YC has
um this should be a product that anybody
has so I think somebody should export
this out and it's like Yelp for
investors where investors have a
reputation on this uh in this app and
it's all you can only write about them
if you had you know like let's say a
a verified interaction with them or
something like that
dude that's great I think I wish I could
have that for a variety of vendors the
things that people ask for most at
Hampton is like hey who's a good lawyer
who's it a good accountant who's this
who's that it's incredibly challenging
to find reviews on vendors including
investors it's super hard to start these
types of businesses but I think the one
uh the
startup Community is so insulated that
you could actually overcome the chicken
and egg problem through Brute Force
because there's not that many investors
and you could find you can quickly see
who's worked with them just by looking
at their portfolio and you could cold
email them and be like give me the scoop
and I think you could manually collect
the data to get this going
um all right here's another one
teacher's pet is what I'm calling this
so this is my first AI idea for you here
so um you're aware of teachers paid
teachers which is a Marketplace it's
like Etsy but instead of buying and
selling handcrafted Goods you buy and
sell
lesson plans quizzes things that
teachers need Teachers Pay Teachers have
you ever heard of this we talked about
it a while we talked about it a while
ago right it's a big business so it was
doing like 80 million dollars a year in
Revenue that's like their take not the
gmv that's their their take and it gets
like 20 million visits a month during
school years
um 300 teachers on this network have
made a million dollars or more
um by selling lessons or selling quizzes
or selling classroom materials to other
teachers so like their new profile
pictures like [__] them kids
I'm a Creator so like these marketplaces
are big and marketplaces for the most
part are pretty unassailable it's very
hard to go compete with something that
has a network effect I think AI is one
of these things that might be able to
crack some Network effects and I think
AI could crack this one so I think you
could train AI
to crawl and learn from all of the
materials on this network you can just
go buy all the materials on this for
probably like less than five hundred
thousand dollars
um and then you could use that as your
training data and you could train AI to
basically become chat GPT for teachers
so you so any teacher should be able to
come to this and instead of going
through and finding what's a good
geography lesson plan and then going and
buying it for fourteen dollars you just
go ask this thing hey I need a geography
lesson plan for fourth grade
um make it fun and interesting and it
should just create one for you so I
think if you created this you could have
a 20 a month subscription just for
teachers to create lesson plans using AI
or quizzes or teaching materials or
whatever teachers
teachers ticket name too yeah you want
to do you have one more I'm big on
providing a name with some with these
ideas uh I think that that really turns
it from like a uh I don't know to like
where's the application form for
Thatcher garbage
what's this you just have this funny
phrase it's for some reason funny to me
you call it in ozepik on-ramp and then
an ozempic off-ramp yeah so these aren't
fully baked ideas but I'll just spitball
it with you all right so when I was
thinking about this you know um
you want to surf on waves if you're
starting a business so what's a wave you
could surf right now oh zempic I think
ozempic is like
If Video is a megatrend guess what
fat loss is amazing
have you tried it yet no no I haven't
tried it but
um I know a lot of people that want to
be on it or get off of it or are I got a
guy I got a guy I could refer him no no
it's expensive though it's expensive
yeah I'm not interested but I know a lot
of people are so I guess the question is
um what could you build around this
ozempic Mega Trend so
um
my brain goes to on-ramps and half ramps
how do you sell something to people that
makes it easier to get it or help people
get off of it so for forgetting it uh if
you go Google just like um
I don't know like how do I take ozempic
or like getting ozempic near me you get
a bunch of like
kind of like uh sponsored links for like
Telehealth services that are gonna try
to like uh you know sign up for this
here's the pills basically but what I
think somebody should do is I think
somebody should go old school with it I
think somebody needs to create a ozympic
hotline and what's the Olympic hotline
so the Olympic hotline is old school
infomercial [__] so you're gonna run ads
on linear TV on Fox News you're gonna be
the my pillow guy you're just gonna be
everywhere that like people who are like
you know 40 to 60 are are clicking and
uh or watching
and you're just going to show people's
Transformations and oozepic and be like
call in now to you know get a free
consultation are you eligible what are
the upsides what are the downsides how
much does it cost where can you find it
so confusing we are going to make it
easy we're gonna give you a free consult
and you basically just become a lead gen
provider for people who are trying to
buy exempting but I think you got to do
like 1 800 like got abs or something
like that right like 1-800 you know but
that goes against all your principles
since you hate which principles
uh
I like to say whatever
we could find them somewhere deep in
that closet uh but I believe one or two
of those principles besides which is
coming out of left field the fact that
you said that you don't want to kill
animals to eat that that that's that's
such a uh curveball coming from you but
I think the other one was I think you
hate Pharmaceuticals no uh no I don't
hate Pharmacy I don't personally take I
don't personally uh try to take a lot of
stuff I try not to be dependent on
anything
um you know as a general rule like
caffeine I don't drink coffee I don't do
I don't do a lot of stuff like that
um you know
people take like you know I don't know
you you love stuff you're like oh I'm I
need nicotine I need this I did I love
carbonated waters and Diet Coke yeah so
I'm I try not to be on any of that stuff
but um but people are this is a business
opportunity I'm not doing this I'm
saying somebody could create a
phone-based way to educate people and
help onboard people or on the other side
you could figure out an off-ramp so so a
lot of people want to stop this either
it's too expensive or they're having
side effects or or they just feel like
they got the weight loss they had they
don't want to keep taking this forever
how do you off ramp and uh I don't know
the answers to that but that's well I'll
tell you the place to go look what's the
answer
you just don't take it nothing bad
happens you just don't take it yeah but
I don't I don't like people try to
regain a bunch of weight right away or
have like any sort of like I don't know
nothing nothing that's this effective
has no cost when you stop I I don't
believe that yeah so basically the the
when the the study that they did was
they took two or three thousand people
they had them do it for six months and
then after six months they had half the
people quit taking it and what they
found was uh at the end of the 12-month
study uh the people took it the whole
time lost
um something like a third of their body
weight so like a 300 pound person was
200 pounds and then the people who quit
taking it they went from 200 pounds back
up to like 230 or something like that so
they gained weight back but they weren't
nearly as fat as they were when they
started so they but they did gain weight
but so yeah an off ramp is fine but I
don't think you have like uh withdrawals
like this is not gonna kill you you're
just gonna like be like Oh I'm hungry
like I want to eat again yeah and maybe
it's just like peer groups or something
I don't know is there something you
could provide to this large group of
people that all have now like one
they're going through this one new
experience and I don't know there's got
to be auxiliary things around it that's
so that's that's a place I would look
for business ideas
um all right I gotta I got another one
for you I heard something the other day
they just really caught my attention I
think it's a cool idea but it's being
done in the wrong way so let's listen to
some podcasts
um and the guy who was talking and it
was like
yeah I did mind support and blah blah
and he started talking about mind
support I was like mine's what a great
name what is that and he was a really
smart guy and he was talking about Game
Theory and blah blah blah and I looked
it up and my sport is essentially the
nerd Olympics so mindsport is a place
that you go if you're uber smart
and um you compete with people in those
games and so those games can range from
chess to Poker to Sellers of Catan or go
or whatever or like Rubik's Cube yeah
like you know if I was like let's just
put it this way Sam if I was to tell you
um you know but this I could solve this
cube in the next you know 90 seconds
you might not think I'm a genius
but you probably don't think I'm an
idiot would that be fair all right are
you gonna solve that right now is that
gonna be part of the show because that
would be great
I wish I could solve this I have never
even gotten close I don't know what the
hell you're supposed to do with this
thing I treated like a fidget spinner
just move it and I'm like oh that's cool
I got two blues and three yellows that's
awesome
on the back and then move on yeah
this so there's the Mind Sports Olympiad
the uh you're you're in the special mind
Sports Olympian
I'm in the mind jog
mine's not moving that fast
um so so basically you go to this thing
and you compete in all these games oh
you can be in your game but you can also
compete in the pentamind championship
which is where you're gonna play five of
these games and I'm like oh my God
you know Coachella for nerds and I was
like this is amazing
um and I just I cannot tell you Sam par
how all in I am on the Mind sport
Olympiad
I want to go I want to watch it live
like I watch the spelling bee live on
ESPN I want to watch The Hard Knocks
documentary about like you know
following five of these people behind
the scenes and watching them stress out
about this I want to adopt one of the
kids in this and just have them be like
you know my 17 year old child
um and most of all I want to hire all
these kids this is so
wrong business model this is not a
tournament with prize money and thanks
to our sponsors Wendy's no no no no no
you've got this all wrong this is a
recruiting event for the elite Minds
under 25 years old and I was like this
is bait to bring together the smartest
nerds in five years these kids are not
going to be playing professional
Settlers of Catan they're going to be
starting companies or working inside
companies and guess where I want them to
work my companies and so I think that
you should take this idea create a
version of this but it needs to be a
elite recruiting service slash job fair
slash demo day for nerds and you need to
basically when they attend they need to
basically somehow like sign over the
rights for you to like send them job
offers for the next five years or like
you know get to invest in them or
something like that because I can't
think of a more valuable talent pool
then the mindsport Olympics you could do
this for gamers in general I love
investing one of my secrets of investing
is I invest in former competitive Gamers
um
you know people who were Elite level at
you know Starcraft or things like that
those people just tend to do really
really well at whatever next game you
throw in front in front of them and once
you throw the money game in front of
them guess what they solve it they
figure it out
um and so there's this listen there's
this thing called the world memory
championships have you heard of this no
sign me up yeah and so they've been
doing this since 1990 1991 and there's a
different game so basically we're gonna
get you we're just gonna give you
thousands of numbers and you have five
minutes and you have to tell us like in
order the numbers and the record for
that is 600 numbers and they only had
five minutes to do it the one hour
number is the same thing except you have
one hour to do it and and the guy who
won that did 4 600 numbers in a row you
remembered that and so they do these 10
different games
and in the same way that the UFC used to
be like this like a bunch of thugs
fighting like it was like barbarians but
now it's like the it's like it's half
WWE and WWF where it's like you know you
slept at my wife now I'm gonna beat you
up at his other half like a movement
yeah your movement is magical look at
his movement it's so smooth this is Pete
physical performance
we need uh we need Dana White you know
or a visit man to buy the world memory
championships and we got to make that
great because I'm looking up the guy who
won it Alex Mullen he's a he's a kid or
no he's or I guess when he won it he was
28. you know what he does for work now
he's an x-ray person at a hospital X-ray
tech X-ray tech memories
why is this guy not working but like
rain is HIPAA compliant what are we
talking about yeah why is this guy not
working for like you know black rock or
Blackstone Just Like Rain Man in his way
to like you know corporate bias I'm
saying baby undervalued assets these are
these are hidden gems uh I'm not all in
on memory because I think memory is like
the pleb version of the the Olympiad
like these other guys are like
strategists but like memory is you know
any rube can do memory really
um
I can't even remember seven numbers let
alone 600.
I can remember two-thirds of any phone
number
uh yeah so that's that's one idea
um okay I got a couple other for you
um let me hit you with with one more
maybe but we were out of time here but
I'm gonna I'm gonna go into overtime
here and give you one more
um let's do one around churches okay so
something you know a lot about another
area that I'm completely unversed with
but I know that other people do it
um
Michael girdley tweeted this out the
other day he said uh 3 500 churches are
closing every year
well what's what's that about what is
that
number and um it's not exactly right
actually like what happens is four
thousand churches closed last year but
like another 3000 or 2 000 opened or
something like that it's like a net
change of 1500 churches uh but but
towards the negative and there is a
bunch of there are a bunch of stats
about this so
um in the CR you know in in traditional
churches so the Christian churches
attendance is down 65 in the last 20
years 65
um and what happens is when the pews are
empty there's less donations so then
these churches end up having to close
down
and uh there's a trend basically they
call them like are you are you Christian
are you Jewish are you Muslim what are
you and there's a there's a group called
The Nuns they're just none I don't know
why they're calling them nuns instead of
like sort of like atheists or whatever
like wait nuns like n-u-n or n-o-n-n-e
yeah that's all that's that's also
confusing when you said nuns that's like
a bunch of ladies in like comments
honestly big slip up on their part yeah
they could be the zeros survey them and
for Gen Z I guess 45 would count as as
none of the above essentially for for
religion and this guy who um studies
churches whatever said that of the three
350 000 Christian congregations in the
United States one-third are like
vulnerable on the brink of collapse
basically like one-third are like in the
red zone and over the next 10 years will
likely close that's a huge number and
what are the opportunities so I think
that there's I think you could approach
this from multiple angles so
again not a specific idea but I do think
you could look at this when you hear a
stat like that that's just that's just
one that gets your attention like when
Jeff Bezos heard the stat that like you
know the internet is growing at twelve
thousand percent a year he's like oh I
better go start Amazon and basically I
think you could do that around around
stats like this so
how are these churches going to close
down
um
that in itself the sort of the vulture
business or the cleanup is the funeral
business for churches I think is kind of
interesting how are the how forget
saving it might help them help them die
with Grace in my neighborhood uh one
block from my house in St Louis they
turned a church into a condo right yeah
exactly so then I found there's this
group called Niagara Consulting Group
and they're basically like we help you
restructure your church what do they
mean by that it's basically
look there's a lot of developers that
are chomping at the bit to turn this
into luxury condos like we help you try
to succeed but if you don't we'll get
you an offer from one of these
developers to turn this into luxury
condos and I was like oh interesting but
in a lot of places they can't even do
that because it's like you know like low
low income areas that there's not real
they just sit there empty
um so I think there's a lot of
opportunity to figure out how to deal
with this I think there's opportunity if
I'm a company like calm
could I take 50 million dollars
and just buy
physical locations across the country in
one year through these searches and just
have a weekly service for meditation and
whatever like
um even have like like you know just
local chapters basically franchisees
that are going to run them
um so I think there's there's something
to be done here whether it's trying to
save them trying to help them fail
gracefully figuring out what's a what's
a pivot you could do for a lot of these
I saw you just put a little Link in here
what you got so that's uh that's ten
Doors Down from my childhood home or my
mom and dad still live
um beautiful it's a church that they
turned into a seven eight thousand
square foot house and as a house it
doesn't look that cool but as like a
meditation area like it does look cool
as an Airbnb fantastic you know yeah but
look it's 1.2 million dollars and it's a
8 000 square foot I mean it's in St
Louis Missouri where I'm from which
isn't that nice but they this company
renovated this church into like a
livable house and then I met these other
guys who turned one into a skate park
they turned an old church into a skate
park
um and so it's like it is pretty
fascinating because a lot of these
buildings
are kind of cool but to have like the
Church of calm
that's kind of dope and then if you're
gonna help them I think this is gonna be
a side hustle so like church near us
they actually have like awesome events
all the time and I love to take our kids
to it because it's like they just put on
great events wholesome fun events for
families and kids
but it's so hard to even know what the
hell like literally the only way I know
is if I drive by they have a little sign
they put like in the front like a for
sale sign but it'll be like we're doing
something this Saturday it's gonna have
popcorn and bouncy houses like oh I'm in
but I only catch it driving by I'm like
these guys just don't know social media
and um I had to call them to be like
hey if I'm like an Indian dude who's not
a member of the church can I still come
get the free popcorn like you know
what's the deal around this are you like
are your doors open yeah they're gonna
have like a color swatch yeah come in
like
you're not white enough exactly like do
you need to have recognized me you know
like how does this work and so I
couldn't even get a hold of them because
I was like they just they have like one
old Facebook page with like you know an
event from 2014.
and I'm like dude churches need better
social media and I was like I think you
could just create like done done for you
social media services for churches if
you wanted to get like a 10 to 20 000 a
month side hustle I think you could just
do that just by going to every single
church just walk in and be like hey your
social media is not very good I can make
it look like this and then you basically
go on Shepard you hire somebody for 800
a month and that person is going to
manage 20 churches social media as for
you because all the churches do hey it's
the same schedule it's every Sunday
um same templates you just need their
color their name and you need to know
like what's going on for them like you
know just manage all of their Instagram
and um you know like social media
accounts for them
so I think that's one that like it's not
that nobody's doing that but
there's plenty of churches that are not
on board that if you just wanted to go
sign up a bunch of clients for 300 to
400 a month you could do that did you do
you remember this so have you heard of a
hill song like when I uh uh it's like
Hillsong Church yeah um when I was
living in Tennessee I've been an Atheist
forever but I was like
a lot of cute girls are going to this I
guess I guess that's the price to be
that's the price they gotta pay so I'll
go to this like so I went to this thing
to like meet some people and uh that's
how I kind of learned about it but
for in the later 2000s there was this
guy who somehow infiltrated Justin
Bieber's camp and he like became Justin
Bieber's like Mentor uh Carl Lentz and
there's a new Netflix show about him but
basically he's like he's like he's like
a smoking hot guy like you know he looks
basically like Justin Bieber in his 40s
like he looked great I don't describe
most men as babes but he's a babe well
he's a babe I mean like objectively like
you know like you're either seven foot
tall or you're not like he's seven feet
tall he's tall I think I uh messaged you
once about him and you were like dude
he's got the thing like you know like
the the diagonal lines that just point
to your crotch it's like it's like an AB
line that you only have if you're super
rip he's got those what kind of Pastor
has those yeah if you're a pastor and
you have that V it's bad news and as as
one could just look at his V and guess
he did some uh I don't know if he did
any illegal things I don't I didn't
frankly I didn't watch the documentary I
don't know I don't think it was rape I
think he just cheated on his wife and
yeah they just had sex with just
everyone
[Laughter]
might do he's also super charismatic
super good looking
um has like a you know a huge following
from being on stage in front of 10 000
people every week or whatever you know
it he's a mega celebrity he was yeah
he's the mega celebrity but he made
Hillsong cool like I even went to one of
those things uh because this girl I was
trying to date was like come to this
thing their music is great yeah so I
went I went to that thing just to be
with this girl and it wasn't worth it
didn't work out but uh
but yeah that's how I learned about some
of this religion stuff dude where I'm
from St Louis all the Catholic churches
are dying man the the all the Catholic
schools are are going by the wayside one
of the more useful things that I learned
when I moved to Silicon Valley was a new
way of looking at businesses that I
hadn't really ever heard before outside
of Silicon Valley which is you most
products are actually a bundle not a
product most things are a bundle and
once you can identify what's in the
bundle you could figure out how to
unbundle that service and make something
better so for example uh Peter Thiel
went on a spree where he was talking
about how universities are a bubble how
the university system is overrated he
was going to launch the teal Fellowship
which would pay you two hundred thousand
dollars to drop out of school and do
something useful with your life and
that's where figma came from and that's
where Oil rooms came from that's where
you know vitalik the creator of ethereum
was it he was a teal I think there's
been 10 billion dollar companies so far
have come from it really actually a very
impressive track record and so one of
the things he said was that they're like
how could you you know it was it was
sort of like taboo to say like you know
who says like
anything against school right like
everybody's message is basically stay in
school kids and he's saying drop out of
school kids and so they're like give you
money how dare you and he's like well
the university is a bundle it's like
it's partially
um education so there are there is
education it's partially
um socialization so you know you go
there to learn how to like party and be
with other kids and date and get drunk
and all that stuff
it's partly
um babysitting so it's basically my kids
not old enough they're not mature enough
to get to the real world yet it's like
four years over here let them simmer a
little bit then they'll be ready
he's like it's partly insurance which is
like a societal Insurance like uh look I
don't care what you do just get a degree
get a college degree because that label
that stamp is going to be whatever he's
like it's partly
um accreditation so like
I don't care if you're the top student
at Harvard but if you got into Harvard
that's a signal that's strong enough for
me as an employer to know that you're
smart right like if I know you went to
Harvard it's a signaling thing so he's
like you're actually buying all of these
things when you buy into University when
you pay the crazy cost of University
and we have to ask ourselves what part
of that bundle is actually important
what part of the bundle is failing is it
actually a weak part of the bundle that
could be unbundled and so what he did
was he switched the accreditation one
he's like cool
what if I created something I have a
brand Peter teal I invest in Facebook I
created PayPal what if I hand-picked you
know 40 of the most promising college
kids and paid them 200 Grand to leave
school now I've
instead of having just like some normal
school badge which is good you get the
teal hand-picked badge which is even
more Elite so I'm gonna like unbundle
the university give you a more Elite
badge
um and then I'm gonna get rid of all the
rest I don't care about the
socialization I don't care about the
rest I'm gonna be 10x better at this
badge and uh you know like YC is 10x
better at University in certain things
than in others and so that's brilliant
yeah so the question is what is the
church bundle the church bundle is a
combination of lecture for learning
Community a place to gather and
congregate every week it's just a
peaceful place like I like going to
church I used to go to church not for
like I kind of like the sermon but I
just love the feeling of being inside of
a church the aura of inside of a church
was just very peaceful and grounding to
me um so it's a peaceful place it's also
therapy slash confession uh so a place
to get things off your chest
um and and kind of with that is like
being absolved of your sins like just
getting a clean slate I think oh okay I
feel less guilty um you know there's
music so some people go for the music
Vibes some people go for the food like
Indian temples all have like free food I
don't know if churches have that or not
but like Indian temples like a lot of
people I know go because they actually
like love the meal uh but it's plus a
good thing
um you show your loyalty to God and so
if you take this bundle of a bunch of
things also dating I I put this on there
like I know a bunch of people that like
they kind of want to meet someone who
has maybe their values or is like right
you know like sure yeah it's like
matches in some way and they're like oh
this is better than going and trying to
approach someone in a bar where it's
noisy and I'm getting rejected like oh
what if I like this is a new sort of
like social scene where I can go
approach somebody all right
so I think one big so the small version
of this idea is like social media for
churches the medium version of this is
like restructure these churches into
condos or figure out some lead gen where
you maybe you you help them as they wind
down to sell off assets or something the
big version of this idea is figure out
how you're going to replace the value
that churches gave people but you do it
in a new way and so like for example
could you create a new
brand in these same venues that's around
I don't know like manifestation or some
[__] like that or meditation or um yoga
like could you create a yoga franchise
that only operates out of churches and
some blend of life that's cool religion
and churches right I start religion and
yoga and like I think those are the Big
Ideas which is replace the function
one of the like be 10x better on one of
those bundles like 10x better on food or
music or the sermon or
um absolving you of your sins like you
know do do you try to be better at 10x
better one of those and you use the
physical locations of churches to like
build that new franchise that's a very
that was a good that was a good speech
you did good on that one thank you
working now now we're gonna have a bunch
we're gonna have a bunch of Soul Cycles
uh on the altar uh which is a lot cooler
than how it is now but that was a good
that was a very compelling argument
thank you I sort of ventured into drunk
ideas territory there but I know you
know a little bit but yeah that was a
good one that was a good one uh I'll let
you that's that's the winner or dribble
the dribble [__] is the is the winner
all right there we go that's it that's
the idea episode uh
you know what to do do they just get all
these ideas for free Sam
well they don't have to pay money oh but
it's not for free
but so they don't support their wallet
but what do they have to do well I think
what they got to do is
go to YouTube go to your podcast app
search my first million hey you gotta
click subscribe you got to click that
button for us because we're out here
churning out million dollar ideas
billion dollar ideas side hustle ideas
for you all on a Labor Day no left I
mean
there's only one right move there's only
one way to pay us back if that's what it
is go subscribe to the channel that is
called the gentleman's agreement we're
not going to go check We're Not Gonna
We're Not Gonna verify this all right
it's Honor Code this is a gentleman's
agreement we did it we did our part now
you do yours that's all all right thank
you that's the five
[Music]
foreign